et nous en avons fait une boîte et dit :
« Les hommes et les femmes sont différents. »
Nous nous y sommes habitués, ne l'avons pas questionné
et cela me fascine,
et je veux dire que c'est assez fou
que nous en parlions encore comme d'un segment
alors que c'est majoritairement un transfert de préjugés.
Je n'en viens pas à cette conclusion à la légère.
Nous avons assez de données
suggérant que le genre n'est pas le meilleur point de départ
pour concevoir et cibler vos marques.
J'irais même plus loin :
à moins que vous ne travailliez
sur une catégorie de produits spécifique à un genre,
probablement que n'importe quelle autre hypothèse sur votre consommateur
vous sera plus utile que le genre.
Nous n'avions pas pour objectif de tirer cette conclusion.
Nous l'avons découverte.
En tant que consultants, nous allons avec nos clients,
comprenons leurs affaires,
et essayons de les aider à trouver des espaces pour développer leurs marques.
Nous croyons que si vous voulez trouver une croissance disruptive sur le marché,
vous devez aller voir le consommateur
et adopter une vision agnostique du consommateur.
Vous devez partir de zéro,
vous extraire des préjugés et segments que vous pensiez importants
pour regarder où est la croissance.
Nous avons créé un algorithme précisément pour cela.
Imaginez que nous ayons une personne
et nous sachions qu'elle fait un choix
au sujet d'un produit ou service.
Je peux bien sûr connaître le genre de cette personne,
d'autres données démographiques, où elle vit, ses revenus et autres.
Je connais le contexte dans lequel cette personne prend une décision,
où elle est, avec qui elle est,
l'énergie, n'importe quoi
et je peux y ajouter d'autres aspects.
Je peux connaître ses attitudes,
son ressenti sur la catégorie,
ses comportements.
Si vous imaginez ce tas de mégadonnées sur quelqu'un --
je vais simplifier,
mais nous avons créé un algorithme pour des tournois statistiques.
Un tournoi statistique, c'est comme demander aux données :
« Données, d'après tout ce que vous savez des consommateurs à ce stade,
quelle est la chose la plus utile que j'ai besoin de savoir
qui m'en dit plus sur les besoins des consommateurs ? »
Le tournoi va avoir des gagnants et des perdants.
Les gagnants sont ces variables, ces dimensions,
qui vous en apprennent beaucoup sur le consommateur :
si vous savez cela, vous savez ce dont il a besoin.
Il y a des variables perdantes qui ne sont pas si pratiques
et cela compte car dans un monde où les ressources sont limitées,
vous ne voulez pas les gaspiller sur des gens qui ont les mêmes besoins.
Pourquoi les traiter différemment ?
A ce stade, je sais que le suspense est soutenable
car je vous ai dit quel était le résultat,
mais nous avons découvert au fil du temps
qu'après 200 projets à travers le monde -- cela englobe 20 pays ou plus --
en substance, nous avons réalisé 100 000 de ces tournois
et, ce n'est pas surprenant, le genre était rarement la chose la plus prédictive
pour comprendre les besoins du consommateur.
Sur 100 000 tournois,
le genre n'est apparu comme la variable gagnante
que dans environ 5% d'entre eux.
Cela est vrai à travers le monde.
Nous l'avons fait dans des lieux avec des rôles de genre
un peu plus prononcés
et les conclusions étaient exactement les mêmes.
Le genre y était un peu plus important que 5%,
mais pas significatif.
Prenons un moment pour bien comprendre.
Peu importe comment vous considérez un consommateur,
probablement que n'importe quoi d'autre
sera plus intéressant pour vous que le genre.
Il y a probablement une chose importante à savoir à son sujet
et vous êtes distrait car vous faites tout d'après le genre.
C'est ainsi que vous jetez de l'argent par les fenêtres.
C'est facile de concevoir des publicités basées sur le genre,
c'est facile de cibler des gens en ligne et à la télé par genre.
Mais ce n'est pas de là que vient la croissance prometteuse.
Si vous êtes une entreprise dans l'alimentaire,
il est bien plus intéressant pour vous
de savoir où les gens mangent, avec qui ils mangent,
s'ils sont axés sur la nutrition.
Toutes ces choses sont significativement plus efficaces et utiles
que de savoir si une personne est un homme ou une femme.
Cela importe, bien sûr,
car si vous mettez en œuvre votre budget limité,
mieux vaut créer des solutions pour différentes occasions
plutôt que d'essayer de cibler les femmes ou les jeunes hommes.
Un autre exemple : les boissons alcoolisées.
Entre 35% et 40% des boissons alcoolisées dans le monde
sont consommés par des femmes
mais « les femmes ne boivent pas de bière ».
Ce sont des choses qu'on entend souvent.
Mais quand un homme et une femme sont au même endroit,
leurs besoins émotionnels et fonctionnels à ce moment précis
sont très similaires.
Il n'y a qu'une exception,
et les exceptions existent,
quand un homme et une femme
sont à un rencard,
l'homme essaye d'impressionner la femme
et la femme essaye de nouer un lien avec l'homme,
il y aura donc un peu de tension,
mais c'est important à savoir.
Il faudra quelques rencards.
Les institutions financières : nous avons beaucoup entendu parler
de la différence entre les hommes et les femmes,
mais parler des hommes et des femmes comme différents
vous détourne de ce qu'il y a en dessous.
Nous avons rendu ça si simple : « les femmes n'aiment pas investir »,
« elles détestent gérer leur argent »,
« les hommes sont agressifs, preneurs de risques »
mais il ne s'agit pas d'hommes et de femmes.
C'est un récit différent.
Il y a des gens qui sont enthousiastes, dynamiques
et éduqués pour gérer leurs finances
et des gens qui ne le sont pas.
Si vous changez la conversation
des hommes et femmes à ce qu'il y a en dessous,
vous arrêteriez probablement d'être si condescendant envers les femmes
et vous serviriez plus d'hommes
qui sont timides quand il s'agit de gérer leurs finances.
Je vais donner un autre exemple.
Si j'en reviens aux femmes qui faisaient du sport,
l'une des choses les plus fascinantes découvertes dans plusieurs pays,
en explorant les articles de sport,
si quelqu'un est compétitif
et en train de faire du sport,
les besoins ne diffèrent pas entre un homme et une femme.
Un athlète est un athlète.
Peu importe que vous soyez un homme ou une femme, vieux ou jeune,
vous êtes un athlète
et à l'instant de la compétition,
cet équipement doit marcher.
Ces femmes footballeuses ont beaucoup en commun avec leurs homologues.
En dehors du terrain, peu importe.
Hors du terrain, elles peuvent aimer la mode ou d'autres choses,
mais sur le terrain, les besoins ne sont pas différents.
Ce ne sont que quelques exemples de catégories où nous avons découvert
que le genre n'était pas le meilleur critère à retenir
et l'argument est
que ce n'est même plus une pression féministe,
nous nous sommes habitués
à utiliser le genre,
et c'est important pour nous de trouver des moyens
de mesure d'autres choses chez les consommateurs
afin de ne pas en revenir au genre.
Je ne suis pas naïve
et je sais qu'il y aura encore de l'appétit
et une aisance à utiliser le genre
mais cela justifie au moins une conversation.
Dans vos affaires, vous devez questionner
si c'est la meilleure vision pour votre croissance.
Si, comme moi, vous êtes quelqu'un qui est dans les affaires,
qui s'inquiète constamment au sujet de son rôle
dans les discussions sociétales plus larges,
si vous écoutez en entreprise et entendez des choses comme :
« Ma cible, ce sont les femmes ou les hommes,
c'est pour les jeunes filles, les jeunes garçons »,
qu'il y a cette conversation sur le genre,
à moins que vous ne travailliez
dans une catégorie de produits très liés à un genre,
prenez cela comme un avertissement
car si vous continuez à avoir ces conversations,
vous continuerez à perpétuer les stéréotypes des gens :
que les hommes et les femmes sont différents.
Car ce sont les affaires, que nous dirigeons une affaire
et nous voulons croître,
remettez en question votre instinct à utiliser le genre
car les statistiques disent
que vous ne choisissez pas la meilleure variable
pour cibler votre produit ou service.
La croissance, ce n'est pas facile du tout.
Pourquoi croyez-vous que la croissance viendra
d'un marché avec une vision aussi désuète que le genre ?
Arrêtons de faire ce qui est facile, faisons ce qui est bien.
Ce n'est pas bien pour votre entreprise, c'est pour la société.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)